community brighton 8 news now is
sponsored by our community pride
partners finley automotive group
southwest medical part of optum care and
silver state schools credit union
welcome back to las vegas now it is
american stroke month so i spoke with
southwest medical the sponsors of this
next segment and a member of the
american heart association to learn more
check it out now it is american stroke
month so we are talking about a very
important topic linda you are with
specialty care at southwest medical and
jennifer you're with the las vegas
american heart association so you guys
are coming together to spread the word
about this important topic um linda
let's start with you we're celebrating
50 years of southwest medical you've
been with the company for a very long
time so just tell us a little bit more
about what you do
i'm trained as a registered nurse but i
serve as the associate vice president of
specialty care at southwest medical
where i work to improve nursing care and
enhance the health outcomes across the
organization as a board member of the
las vegas american heart association
tell us about what you do and what you
bring to the table with this partnership
yes i mean we love to partnership with
our doctors and all of our medical staff
american stroke month is very important
we need to teach and raise awareness
about the prevalence of strokes and how
important it is to
recognize all the signs and symptoms how
do you reduce the risk of a stroke
knowing your blood pressure is
key
you need to talk to your doctor about
ways to improve your health your
well-being but keeping your blood
pressure in a healthy
range
is very important and it reduces it
greatly reduces your risks of having a
stroke
and i think an important point to this
is that you know a stroke can happen
anytime anywhere at any age correct any
age any time and it can be prevented
um largely through education and
lifestyle changes such as
moving more walking eating smart
and
certainly knowing what your blood
pressure is and keeping that healthy in
a healthy range again
very very important absolutely and can
you explain the fast
approach
yes so fast is a very important acronym
to remember
if your face is drooping
your arm is weak
and you're having
speech difficulties it's time to call
9-1-1 and lastly jennifer where can
viewers learn more about strokes you can
find plenty of free resources and plenty
of education at struck.org
and linda any final thoughts on this
topic and thank you for all that you and
southwest medical have done for this
community
i'm you're very welcome it means the
world to us to be able to give back to
the community that we live and work in
and um southwest medical has been doing
that for the past half century
um we're dedicated to helping
organizations like the american heart
association and as part of our year-long
anniversary we'll be introducing you to
other community partners who make
southern nevada such a wonderful place
to live and work
southwest medical has created a strong
foundation of caring over the last 50
years and here's to the next 50.
thank you again to southwest medical for
sponsoring this segment there's more las
vegas now after this